the first thing I heard in a graduate
school class was a great man that's
named Jeff I mentioned him say that life
is too short to read a hundred books you
should try to be really knowledgeable
about three books means you have to read
him for a long time and he said this
book should be one of the three he made
Shakespeare and Plato's Republic having
said that the Bible which he seemed also
to encourage one to read is not the same
kind of thing so I the first thing I
heard was I need to know this book and
it takes time so I've been reading it
since 1974 I have never had a long
period of time in my life when I did not
attend to it I teach it here now we send
it to all the freshmen I have something
to do with that that's a frightening
thing to do everybody knows that every
sounds a little complicated right I
brought my toy Aristotle here this
morning so you can see how friendly he
is the reason to do it is we all have a
common problem everybody has one problem
how do you live well and we're in charge
of that we human beings in our
well-being our happiness depends upon
how we do that and then I come here and
ethics is the first great book written
about that subject and in my belief the
best book ever written if you keep its
arguments alive in your soul and develop
your knowledge of those arguments
there's this tremendous reward that
comes to you you can understand I argue
better what you're supposed to be doing
with your life the greatest self-help
book ever written
you
[Music]